there's an attempt to silence porn star
stormy Daniels by president Trump's
lawyer yeah that's kind of sad that in
that sentence the most degrading job
mentioned was president Trump's lawyer
that's the job his parents must be so
ashamed President Trump he is planning a
meeting about violence with the heads of
the video game industry yeah
however some people worry that it's just
a trap so that Trump can deport the
Mario Brothers so stupid in the
Northeast one million people are without
power because of a blizzard yeah
and in Wisconsin 1 million people are
without power because of gerrymandering
now that was that one was just for the
New York Times there's one guy watching
oh yeah very good Godin nicely then it's
come out that under President Trump
abstinence only education is making a
comeback yeah yeah
in fact Melania Trump said abstinence
saved my marriage
[Music]
very strange technique well now now he
feels a lot of pressure yeah yeah now
you're pointing it out
you